if you have twenty thousand or hundred
thousand dollars on hand to go buy a
Lamborghini there they want to know
where that cash came from how do you
have that much cash on hand so something
gets triggered when you buy something
that's expensive yes and it basically
goes the IRS goes oh [ __ ] someone's
buying something expensive let me see
where this money came from
yes it's triggered so something
automatically gets triggered yes okay
now it's very interesting so if you had
this million dollars and you just want
to buy Snickers for the rest of your
life you're good IRS never knows but
exact that million you want to buy some
house you wanted to ain't like that the
IRS gets triggered look what he says in
the first episode he says you can go buy
groceries for the rest of your life but
what's you don't wanna buy groceries you
want to be rich and go on vacation to a
beautiful resort come on I'm a
millionaire I want to live like a
millionaire of course okay so we need to
clean the money yes so we need to buy
clean the money basically means we need
to make that money that can't purchase
anything legal so it can purchase
whatever the [ __ ] I want and then IRS
Minds their own business and then you
can still do it later on in cash but you
can say if they come after you can say
I'm gonna show you exactly how I got a
million dollars in cash on okay what is
the most common way to clean that money
we have a million it we let's say we
made it from drug [ __ ] who cares a
massage parlor a casino would be the
golden ticket at cleaning money now they
do that in the show they get to a casino
I'm not ruining anything there's a
season three two haven't died yet so you
know must be legit they get a casino
why is casino the best it's this simple
when you clean money you want to show
that you made as much income as possible
you want to cook your books yeah so you
don't want to say that you made ten
million you want to do 20 million or
thirty million dollars in revenue the
more the merrier
right this guy has five hundred million
dollars to clean so what you want to do
in any business whether it be a
restaurant or casino or a nail salon is
you want it to make it look like the
customers put that money into your
system right not your dirty money so if
I have a ten million dollar a I have ten
million dollars in a duffle bag that's
dirty that the cartel gave to me yeah
and you go to a casino and you know the
owner
you own the casino people gamble there
all you have to do at the end of the
night Lewis is on a really simple basis
is make it look like your casino make
twenty million dollars as opposed to the
actual ten million dollars it made right
a casino is easy because of casinos a
cash business people don't play roulette
with their credit card right they put in
cash they get chips no one no IRS no
federal agent is gonna track down every
single person that attended the casino
that night and say tell me exactly how
much you spent question if you buy ten
thousand dollars worth of chips or more
is the IRS alerted I believe they are so
then you're still thought well they're
not alerted you're they're alerted when
you win $10,000 and wha but if you lose
which is what you would want to do if
you're laundering money through a thing
you could basically lose an infinite
amount of money in the casino I mean
that's the whole point of a casino the
odds are you're gonna [ __ ] lose right
so then you wash it that way okay so
that's later on early on the season they
buy a [ __ ] restaurant what are the
most common ways to launder money like
you hear people do it through a
restaurant or a nail salon you always
hear like these Vietnamese nail salons
are actually front for drug money etc
how would you launder money through one
of these businesses you lie about the
amount of manicures you're getting yeah
you lie you cook your books off so that
all in the books so wait you really do
ten girls nails but at the end of the
day you're like no we actually did 20
pass for 20 exactly an Italian
restaurant we sold in real life tonight
ten lasagnas we report that we did
thirty Lazar we did thirty lasagnas okay
perfect
I understand it it makes sense